[تصفيق]
تتوسع حمله التضامن مع المعتقلين في مبادئ
تعرف بقضيه التامر على امن الدوله
الداخليه والخارجي
الحزب الجمهوري الذي اعتقل رئيسه عصام
الشامي في القضيه نفسها اضافه الى قياديين
اخرين من جبهه الخلاص المعارضه يؤكد في
وقفه احتجاجيه ان استهداف المعرضين ياتي
لضرب التجربه الديمقراطيه والنيل من
الحقوق والحريات في مثل هذا الظرف الخانق
في ازمه
اولا اقتصاديه قبل كل شيء ولا اخال هذه
المداهمات وهذه الايقافات العشوائيه التي
تفتقر الى سنه قانوني والتي تستقر الى
اخلاقيات لا اخالها الا تغطيه على هذه
الاخفاقات
لم تختصر حمله الملاحقات القضائيه على
المعارضين فحسب بل طالت نشطاء ونقابيين
واعلاميين
بينهم رئيس النقابه الوطنيه للصحفيين الذي
وصف ما تقوم به السلطه بالمحرقه ثم محرقه
تعملها السلطه اليوم ضد كل الناس اللي
قاعده تعبر على اراها تمارس في حقها في
التظاهر تمارس بحقها في التعبير ولا
تواجهها السلطه
القوه وبالابحاث وبالمحاكمات بهدف الترهيب
وفي ظل تواصل الصمت وزاره الداخليه
والنيابه العامه والقضاء يبقى الموقف
الرسمي مقتصرا على الرئيس قيس سعيد
الذي اتهم في اكثر من مناسبه خصومه
بالارهاب والتامر والخيانه وقال انه يعمل
على انقاذ الدوله التونسيه منهم
الى الامام ولا عوده الى الوراء ابدا
ونعمل عن قاده دوله التونسيه
وتمكين التونسيين والتونسيات من حقهم في
الحياه
الكريمه
ويرى متابعون ان موجه الاعتقالات وحاله
الاحتقان ستستمر في ظل استمرار الانسداد
الذي تعيشه البلاد على اكثر من مستوى
اثارت موجه الاعتقالات وعمليات الدعم التي
شهدتها تونس تمديدا واسعا وانتقادات
داخليه وخارجيه في حين يمضي سعيد قدما في
مشروعه الذي يقول انه سيوقظ الدوله وينهي
حاله الخراب التي تعيشها